I like the water and I like boats so I
guess that explains it I worked in a
garage for a while as a mechanic and
after about a year of that I went
fishing with my father who has been
fishing his whole life and Here I am
still fishing
most of the stuff they have to have at
the same day or they wanted the same day
anyhow so it's not an overnight thing
that's just go home at the end of the
day my wife calls it a toy jaw well I'm
home you know before I was gone
week ten days you know fishing so they
keep asking me when I'm gonna retire and
I tell them when I stop having fun so
some of the animals that we get the dog
fish especially they study the eyes and
years ago they used to study the blood
system and put different colors in it
skates you work on skates for a while or
working on stuff in this case I use and
that stuff holding that net back and not
knowing or something in it finding out
there's something in it you know it
makes you feel good everything's working
and somebody will be happy with it you
can't keep coming in with nothing very
long and somebody be on your ear you
know because we had gone today we were
there last week but a lot of times you
go back to the same spot you say oh I
know where they are now but they got
tails and they can swim they're gone you
know because today the weather
conditions we really couldn't hunt
around too much today we had to kind of
go in the right direction so we can get
slaughtered all around and they're still
there so we got to go back tomorrow and
there's nothing guaranteed it'll be
death we have to find him some other
place but when my father was there they
needed 200 a day and when I started here
they probably needed 5060 a day and now
it's cut down this past summer well
probably needed only 2530 big ones but
part of that is they don't have the
money you know grant saw Tufts again and
also they've been working on one thing
and they can't find what they want so
they go to something else
you